LORNA GIBSON: My
name's Lorna Gibson.
I'm the professor
for 3.054, it's
a course on cellular solids.
And I've been working
on cellular solids
since I was a graduate
student, since I did my Ph.D.
And cellular solids
are materials
that are made up of
an interconnected
network of struts or plates.
And there's examples like
engineering honeycombs
and foams, and there's
lots of examples in nature.
Things like wood and cork and
there's a type of porous bone.
And there's lots of
examples in medicine too.
Tissue engineering
scaffolds, for example.
So my background is
in civil engineering,
and in civil engineering
we study structures.
And typically people
think of large structures
like bridges or buildings.
But in fact when we analyze
the cellular solids,
we use the same
kind of mechanics.
It's just the scale
is very much smaller.
So we're looking at structures
where the scale might
be hundreds of microns or
millimeters, things like that,
but the same sort of mechanical
principles apply to that.
OK, so I grew up in
Niagara Falls, in Ontario.
And people always
think of Niagara Falls
as being the waterfall
and all the tourist stuff,
there's a casino there now.
But in fact, there's loads and
loads of big civil engineering
works in Niagara Falls,
mostly associated
with the hydroelectric
power station.
So when they make hydroelectric
power in Niagara Falls,
the power station is actually
about a mile downstream
from the Falls.
And what they do is they have
a big hydraulic gate that
goes into the river
and it diverts water
from the river above the Falls
into a whole series of canals
and tunnels and there's
a big reservoir where
they store water.
And then the water
from this reservoir
goes into the
penstocks, the tubes
that go down to the turbines
and then make the electricity.
Niagara Falls is not a big town,
but if you drive around Niagara
Falls, you see these canals,
you see the reservoir,
you see the big power station.
And so there's
these really huge,
impressive civil
engineering works.
And my father worked for
an engineering company
in Niagara Falls
and they specialized
in the design of
hydroelectric power stations,
and I think that's how I got
interested in engineering.
So I've been interested in
bird watching for some time.
Mostly just because
birds are beautiful
and there's all sorts
of interesting behaviors
you can see with birds.
But since I started
doing research
on cellular solids
and, in particular,
teaching this course,
I realize there's
lots of examples of things
about birds that have
to do with cellular materials.
So for instance,
some people had once
told me that woodpeckers
avoid head injury and brain
injury by having a
special cellular material
in between their
brain and their skull.
And that this acted kind of
like a foam in a bicycle helmet.
That it would absorb the
energy of the impact.
And I thought oh, well,
I like bird watching
and I study cellular materials,
I should find out about this.
So I started looking
into it and people
had looked at the anatomy of
the woodpecker skull and brain.
And, in fact, there is no
special cellular material.
But by that point, I
was kind of hooked.
And I actually did a
project at one point
looking at why it
was that woodpeckers
don't get brain injury.
And it's largely a scaling law.
It has to do with the fact that
their brains are very small.
Another aspect of birds that
has to do with cellular solids
is how birds make
themselves very light.
And here we have an owl skull.
This owl, unfortunately,
had an accident with a car.
But somebody picked up its body
and took it to Mass Audubon,
and I got this from somebody
at the Massachusetts Audubon
Society.
And if you look at
the skull-- I don't
know if you can do
a close-up here--
if you look at
the skull, you can
see there's a dense layer
of bone on the outside
and there's another dense
layer bone on the inside,
and there's a sort of foamy
layer bone in between.
And that's called a
sandwich structure.
And this foamy type of bone
is called trabecular bone.
And that's one of the
things that I study.
And it turns out that
particular structure gives you
a very stiff, strong,
lightweight structure.
So you can see an example of
how cellular materials are
used in engineering but here
sort of manifested in the owl's
skull in making the
skull very light.